sure so just to guide you a little bit
if you recall what we say or what are
the area i premiere on what kind of
assuming is the numbers are right okay
but we know we don't live in some fair
to see where it's like yes I happen to
know that's exactly 500 meters even if
we had like laser accuracy very things
let's still be off by a little bit so
this is just getting the actual numbers
but we know it might not be 5.1 we might
be a not going to say it but we don't
maybe this or it could be this all right
so what you see on what those are if you
take all your lowest like what's the
lowest the area convenient and once the
greatest the area could be both of those
are not going to be the same as this
debacle so what's the farthest away
what's the biggest the error could
possibly be in terms of the difference
of these two this that's what we're
trying to get it okay if that's not
enough when I pack the action version
what do you guys want to do now down
yeah I let's do the easy bit first okay
pencil one the someone already worked
out what our area and perimeter off 17.3
for me to sweat yeah okay and a proven
up examples yeah 17 years now I'm just
going to put by the way because the
original question has some measurements
on it right and then given to you to one
decimal place it is reasonable to assume
that if all are doing is adding them all
together I still have that one decimal
place of accuracy do you beg does that
make sense like for example it was just
a coincidence like it's literally I just
put these maybes thumbs up it could have
been seven point two point one or 16.9
or whatever so I really do actually have
an extra decimal place even if the
number ends up as a whole number okay
right now then you actually start to
need to get to working here so in order
to get lower and upper limits you kind
of need to do the lower and upper limits
of these guys first before you can
progress right so for example I've
measured its 5.1 but I could be lower
than that what could it be instead of
fun to put one
okay um yeah 5.05 because on to the
nearest tenth animator which means half
of that is the error on either side does
that make sense right so 5.05 beaters it
could actually be that's all or
alternatively it could be well if I'm
under vision it was actually looking at
that what's the longest it could be 5.15
because if you remember for instance if
I if I looked it is like all 5.04 I
would have rounded this down yeah and if
this was like 5.16 I would have rounded
up so in either case I wouldn't have got
the five foot one that i think i have in
the same way 3.41 of my lower and upper
belts gonna be 3.5 and the biggest it
could be would be 3.5 cool so remember I
think you had a little bit of reading
we're having that and we going up and
down ok cool that was the tricky bit
these days just come from using those
not as appropriate right so we'll do an
area first I one thing out what's the
smallest the area could possibly be that
means i need the smallest measurements
for the legs right so that's going to be
this fan here and this guy here when i
multiply those two together that's the
small as the actual area could be
obviously going to get a whole bunch of
decimal places can solid tell me what
the long run boy do you want to give me
a few other places how many do you
actually have it's for more okay so nice
like that yes okay now just like I did
before you notice here I was like hey I
got 270 meters exactly but I actually
have more accuracy than that here I
noticed it's really the reverse by doing
the calculation I've got point 9 175 but
I don't really have that much accuracy
to why right I actually should have much
less than that
is that good yes being a pastime so this
in fact if we approximate it I think
16.9 would be good because we did have
one decimal place before after all I
will point out a 2 f which is the
exercise that I skipped over because
it's not dealing with something that I
want to address sort of actually answers
this question or try stylist in this
question of well it should be one dose
place or zero decimal places or two or
what what how far do you go okay can
someone get me an upper one down seven
seven seven five so that's around that
very good so there's always the whole
square meter between your lower and
upper that's quite a big budget all
right that was area could we get some
primitive measurements there this should
be easier
1668 and upper so no subject okay cool
now by the way you might remember we do
saw this last time right there's still
an era there's still like a larger the
good where it's like I'm not really sure
but it's much smaller for Prudhoe then
for area like we're a whole square meter
apart whereas here it's like less than
half a bit what's the reason for that
difference why is this so much error
etiquette here versus here
multiplication multiplication table
today should compounds the areas that
you've got faster okay so so far so good
now the last part what are the backs of
errors for each of them so when I think
about what I actually measured and how
far up and down I could be okay let's
have a look at this so for example
what's the difference between what I
think it is and they'll lower live it
what's the difference between those two
numbers so that looks like point four
four 0.44 square meters yeah okay on the
money right so just keep that you're
buying what about when you compare the
upper one is that going to be a bigger
difference or a smaller one it's going
to be bigger and we actually noticed
this before when you're doing areas the
bigger one will always end up even
bigger that the smaller one is smaller
so what is the difference between 70
point good point 3443 wait for three you
did you do that use the exact were there
okay I see alright so again this sort of
you have a valid answer there based on
what you've written before i'm just
going to write it based on what i've
rounded to because it's sort of
consistent with my move on sir yes give
me this one yeah there's no reason why I
couldn't 17.3 because it again it's the
same level accuracy that I have over
here so what do you think about this
what's the difference now this is point
for difference and this is point five
isn't it Plus meter square so this is
one of the weird things that you might
feel a little uncomfortable that you
like
what is the right one and the answer is
like we're all we've all got slightly
different measurements and that's the
whole point of thinking about error in
the first place right so i'm going to
write based on the numbers I've gone to
the board the maximum error would be
half a square meter because it's a
difference between these two which is
bigger than the difference between these
two okay obviously if you've got more
decimal places of accuracy then you'll
have a slightly different number but
you'll still have identified the
difference between what you think it is
and the upper limit of true error do we
have a nice material dip sorry massive
error for the print yeah this was much
easier isn't it because this is exactly
halfway between those two okay and the
other way you can think about it is you
grab arrow point zero five four times um
which party you ask you about well I
have simulated ok so for perimeter from
her luck um yes it is because what
happens is the more times you add it
right if you're adding something and
adding it out of the game you're going
to subtract that error remember I said
I'll every time I've measuring a little
bit off I could be that's five
centimeters isn't it I could be 57 years
off to get to the lower measurement
you're going to subtract it four times
I'm going to take away five centimeters
for every one of my measurements when I
do the upper one i'm going to add that
same for lots of five centimeters so I
still end up 20 centimeters up or 27 yrs
down whereas when I do area there's
multiplication involved so something
different it will complicate is happy
and that's why you're not half way